I have friends who make $47,000 a year
and are the happiest people I know their
work life balance is on point they're
part of two soccer teams they play video
games they watch every show they want
they take two vacations that they scrap
together and they're freaking happy as
hell and I know tons of people who I
grew up with in the Silicon Valley boom
who have hundreds of millions of dollars
in their bank account and are as
miserable and as lonely and as broken as
you'll ever see 7 billion people need to
change the conversation what success
looks like it is not to make a billion
dollars it is to actually wake up in the
morning and be in a good mood